y cultura france24 se sostiene en casa
pero esta opción nunca fue viable para
el sector que en europa revive un
segundo cierre de media se prevé que no
sobrepase diciembre pero la desolación
común es que todos los gobiernos
sellaron la cultura cuando fue la última
en poder abrir en italia el cese es
total aunque va por zonas mientras que
en españa varía según comunidades con
gran excepción para los museos
protestamos porque una vez más nos
impiden hacer nuestro trabajo estamos en
verdadera dificultad es injusto que las
iglesias puedan abrir mientras las
tiendas pequeñas en centros comerciales
donde no hay mucha gente tengan que
cerrar
a diferencia del cierre que inició en
marzo varias naciones europeas han
otorgado ayudas no obstante el gran
reclamo es si esto era evitable sabiendo
que el sector tiene protocolos y no
registra apenas brotes en españa el
debate está en la socialización pre y
post evento en francia- que depende de
la política valorar a la cultura como
esencial tras negar la apertura de
librerías centenarias como la parisina
shakespeare en que han perdido el 80 por
ciento de las ventas que sólo han
remontado por una ola de pedidos en el
país premios como el goncourt se han
para evitar que amazon gane
aunque el medicine siguió adelante para
animar domicilios literarios
entiendo por qué la gente usa más las
plataformas en línea pero tiene un costo
y resulta agotador que cuanto más grande
eres más puedes evitar las leyes o los
impuestos debemos decir que cuanto más
pequeño eres más caras y más complejas
son las cosas en ser vendemos demoscopia
que te tensa este año solo las
plataformas han vencido y más y como
netflix devuelven a sophia loren a la
pantalla hacía 11 años desde nine de rob
marshall que no veíamos a la leyenda
italiana si bien en la vita davanti s su
hijo eduardo ponte y logra todavía más y
es plasmar aún a loren espontánea real
que aunque quisiera sería incapaz de no
conectar con este drama de la novela de
gone manga gay recordemos que antes de
actuar para vittorio de sica a los 17
fue una niña de la guerra y su rol
madame rosa superviviente del holocausto
evoca eso también que como su madre y su
abuela es una luchadora que para ganarse
la vida cobija a niños de compañeras
hasta quemamos un huérfano inmigrantes
senegaleses aterriza en su cotidiano
forjando una amistad digna de lagrimones
oscar 60 años después de aquel por la
cuchara para loren ha sido un regalo
rodar de nuevo con su hijo pero el
regalo de trama social y música de laura
pausini nos lo hace a nosotros
humanidad es sólo una pizca la el plan
de ciprés de la vida
para cuando manu nos han importado ese
grandioso
[Música]
contra mi libro bruto el 0 1
de netflix tampoco podemos obviar su
serie reina porque la cuarta de the
clowns se supera sin serlo nos hacen
monárquicos cuando es la más dura contra
la realeza flaquea sólo en dar
profundidad a margaret thatcher ya su
gestión invitada por una en william
anderson que tensa a la reina isabel
desde otro poder en femenino pero la
tortura mayor bordada por el mag
covering y su mirada triste es para lady
be peter morgan retrata una casa que no
traga el encanto natural de diana y que
se lo hace pasar mal aunque no tanto
como el príncipe carlos su amor por
camila parker bowles humilla y desprecia
a la princesa del pueblo
sur
[Música]
a mí no
si wake see the ground tiene cierta
oscuridad el retorno de foo fighters es
entre tinieblas y es puramente
intencional en febrero de 2021 la banda
de seattle lanzará medicine and midnight
pero como adelanto en james en su décimo
disco será el más tenebroso y
diferenciado de su estilo
este nuevo foo fighters nos adentra por
ahora en una pesadilla que el vocalista
dave grohl ha revivido durante 37 años y
es una colina con un árbol muerto y un
ataúd en llamas
[Música]
o puesto hasta un escenario de pasaje al
cielo nos lleva a la cantautora chilena
paloma mami en su tema for ya no sólo
prueba que el desamor puede ser elegante
a ritmo de soul dembow sino que a este
paso conquistar a en la cima urbana su
bilingüismo ya ha sonado junto a major
lazer dice tangana
[Música]
aunque se mueve
precisamente con el apodado el madrileño
nos despedimos de tanganas llevaba
tiempo con un estribillo en mente que al
caer en su producto ahora lis moto en lo
que según él es la canción más valiosa
de su carrera esta rumba chapa como han
definido y que cuenta con la húngara y
niño de elche es contagiosa a más no
poder pero además está llena de capas
una es la visión futurista de alice y
tangana que ya en demasiadas mujeres
innovaron en estética y electro
flamencos otras son todas las
referencias a rosalía a la que desde
2015 ha invocado en sus creaciones tanto
que el desamor ha hecho que hasta el sea
más rosalía este 2020 muy gracias por
estar ahí y cuídense
por lo que necesitas
cuando más falta
[Música]
cuando menos lo esperas
cuando nos atendió
se fueron las ganas
[Música]